what's up guys so where the hell am i
while my wife and I are currently on
vacation filming our fourth annual scary
movie special every single October we do
a really fun scary movie special for you
guys and this year we're doing something
really cool and just to tease it a
little bit we are going to be talking
about movies that take place in cabins
in the woods of course of the horror
genre so we actually went to a cabin in
the woods and we're filming skits here
we're doing really cool stuff and that's
why my Luke Cage review is here because
I watched the entire series Friday
Saturday Sunday then I drove like 8
hours to this really cool cabin in
Tennessee but my vacation is not going
to stop me from talking about Luke Cage
so let's get into this show first off
this is one badass character I love Mike
Colter as this character he was really
great in Jessica Jones season 1 and I
was so pleased when I found out that I
got to get an entire show surrounding
this character and he's just as
compelling if not more compelling in his
own show this guy is brilliant as this
character he adds such a great layer of
humanity to this guy and I started to
care about him a lot more than I
expected because he is an invulnerable
character he has skin that's essentially
steel he has super strength you can't
really do much of anything to the guy in
regards to hurting him and so the show
uses emotional torment very wisely as
the things that hurt this character and
that's one of the best things about Luke
Cage the fact that it doesn't focus as
much on the fact that he is a superhero
and it focuses more on building him as a
character and making him interesting and
making the people surrounding him and
his environment interesting and this
being the third of the Marvel Netflix
shows after Daredevil and Jessica Jones
we can see now that that really is what
they're focusing on character yeah
Daredevils awesome and he kicks a lot of
ass but the show is really a character
driven show as was Jessica Jones which
didn't focus that much on her superhuman
abilities Luke Cage is very similar in
this first season to me was very
satisfying because it did focus more on
character and it made me care about him
I wanted to see what was going on in his
world more so than seeing him beat up a
bunch of people which trust me when that
happens it's pretty awesome Mike Colter
is such a badass in this role he owns
every minute of screen time he gets the
supporting characters in the show are
also very good especially misty Knight a
detective who is on luke cage's trail
trying to figure out where all of these
bodies are originating these dead bodies
they're showing up all over Harlem Theo
Rosie as shades finally gets her role
that's not in win the bow breaks oh man
painful flashbacks he was suitably
over-the-top and it worked for his
character he says everything very fast
with pauses and very deep you know we
need to take out Luke Cage and you need
to do it for me
he was like the kid and Malcolm in the
middle who had breathing problems the
character of Mariah Dillard played by
alfre woodard I'm so sorry if I
pronounced her name wrong because she is
so great in this show it's a character
with a lot of layers she starts out one
direction you think you know what this
character is going and without spoiling
anything there's a turning point in this
show at about the halfway point that's
integral to the direction of the show
and once certain things happen I had no
idea where the show was going it was
completely unpredictable and from that
moment on I was watching a show where I
genuinely had no idea what was going to
happen because I was positive things
were progressing in a certain way and
when something occurs that changes all
of that I was really surprised by that
and that's hard to do because you know
I've seen so many films and TV shows
it's really hard to have something truly
subvert your expectations and Luke Cage
did it in one specific regard that I
can't really get into it's unfortunate
that alfre woodard was also in civil war
as a completely different character
because that kind of messes up the MCU
continuity and that was a mistake I
guess on the casting of civil wars part
whatever I can overlook it because
mistakes happen there's also the evil
character known as cottonmouth who is
the biggest gangster in all of Harlem
he's like the Frieza of Harlem he's
killing his own
henchmen he's killing tons of innocents
left and right but he doesn't under the
guise that he is in some way cleaning up
Harlem that he is adding something to
Harlem despite his horrific acts and
this guy's played by Maher shala Ali who
was one of the best parts of Free State
of Jones or cinematic nyquil as I like
to call it and played to a tee you can
see that he's relishing every moment
he's on screen chewing up the scenery
there's a lot of over-the-top acting in
this show but it kind of works because
the roots of Luke Cage are from the
1970s the roots of the comic book were
also very over-the-top
it's definitely attributing that era of
film in the 70s where there were a lot
of really over-the-top action movie
starring mostly african-american actors
things like shaft you know where it's
just like a really badass guy who gets
all the ladies and you do all the cool
stuff on the streets and that's one of
the things I loved about Luke Cage
because it is a show that takes itself
seriously and has a lot of intense drama
and there's also a really heartfelt
message woven throughout season one in
which the creators are really crying out
to the youths of today to avoid crime
and to do good things in their life and
even the adults of today you are
involved in criminal activities to set a
better example for the future
generations and that's definitely a
message in this show that I really
appreciate it and it does take itself
seriously in that way but branching back
what I was just talking about it also
has that whole fun element of it where
Luke Cage says things like sweet
Christmas you know he acknowledges his
silly awesomely fun roots and I got to
say I thought about this a lot I think
Luke Cage season 1 has my favorite score
of any MCU film or TV show the music in
this show is euphoric I love jazz
already so that kind of helps but it has
a lot of really great modern hip-hop
mixed with contemporary jazz and classic
jazz it's a really really cool score as
for flaws with the first season it gets
narratively inconsistent towards the
last couple episodes it gets a little
silly as a character is introduced it
gets a little too over-the-top for its
own good a costume is introduced for one
of the main
villains and I was just like this isn't
really working for me some of the
narrative isn't perfect it doesn't flow
as well as it could it jumps back and
forth sometimes between less compelling
characters and a little bit too much
filler where we really just want to get
back to Luke Cage being Luke Cage being
a badass trying to survive but it didn't
really hinder me from wanting to watch
the show more and more it's filmed
extremely well it's a beautiful-looking
show in regards to color correction it
looks like it fits within the universe
of Daredevil and Jessica Jones and
that's a good thing because they all
feel like they can coincide with one
another it's a love letter to Harlem
it's a call to action to avoid violence
it's an entertaining superhero show with
great performances I'm going to give
Luke Cage season 1 and a - I'm looking
forward to iron fist and the defenders
Netflix is really owning the superhero
scene right now
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more videos
very soon
and I hope you guys enjoy our upcoming
Halloween skit we're going to do later
in October you guys are the best thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]